we are clowning around it is
international clown week that's okay
rocco
katy perry tickets oh okay yeah you
better call in for that
did i win
no
who better to celebrate with than rocco
from circus circus how's it going oh
it's going good yeah how's it going with
you very welcome
okay very good we haven't spoken in a
couple of years yeah you know
all right but we're coming out of this
pandemic rocco and you guys have a bunch
of cool family fun activities going on
yes mostly weekend
well but of course yes we have the
flying axe we have jugglers
we have foot jugglers
we have contortionists that's good that
one always hits my back when i watch
that one and uh we have a whole bunch of
other stuff come on down come and see us
listen you've been in this for three
decades now you actually went to clown
school you were telling yes i did i went
down to clown college from venice
florida way back in 1985.
so i'm old
i'm right there with you rocco what
compelled you to get into the world of
clowning i didn't want a real job
what can i say what do you get out of
clowning oh i like to make people laugh
and happy yeah you know because this
world how it is now like
sound we need more laughter we do we do
definitely the last two and a half years
have been tough for everybody yes
all right well these are going to be
great family fun activities all right
and how do you like to celebrate
yourself how do i celebrate yeah yeah
well with international clown week
we do lots of fun stuff we throw pies in
our faces we get our big shoes clean but
i wearing small shoes today because i
had to drive um
we got our wigs washed do we get
pedicures and
manicures see my hands where am i
looking here see how nice those are all
right thank you so much for coming in
ron can i do a trick real quick oh you
can do it real quick while we're
wrapping up here you can see rocco at
circus circus folks and what's your
trick i'm going to balance this broom on
my chin
believe it or not
here we go
well done rocco thank you
[Laughter]
back to you